oh you are way more fun than my last
lawyer i will kill for you megan
solid back
[Music]
hot girl summer has turned into hot girl
court session as megan the stanley made
a guest cameo in marvel's she-hulk
attorney at law and of course she was
serving some major body audio in court
[Music]
the episode plays out where jen played
by tatiana maslany is hired by her
former colleague dennis played by drew
matthews as he is looking to sue an
asgardian shapeshifter who catfished him
out of thousands of dollars pretending
to be megan the stallion well to be fair
i thought i was dating megan the
stallion i'm sorry what sorry you
thought you were dating megan the
stallion a multiple grammy award winner
mega star megan the sound what part of
shape shifter did you not get
and while court is in session the camera
pans to reveal a special guest sitting
in the courtroom
that's right there's only one making a
stallion
maslany caught up with entertainment
tonight to recall the experience saying
it was the best day of my life it was so
great i was and am a massive fan of hers
i nearly died like i couldn't even deal
with it
you gotta love megan the stallion the
hilarious episode wraps with she-hulk
revealing that meghan has officially
hired the marvel superhero as her very
own law attorney but she hulk namie
megan as her favorite client and of
course one of meg's most famous moves
hey there's my new favorite client
just just your signature there
and then just initially good
and initials up here
he almost hasted that num num num num
eat it up hopefully okay three two one
you know i'm the hottest you ain't never
gotta heat me
you